fouilles étrangères pour ouvrir la grotte au
public nous avons trouvé cette grande cour l'une des
plus grandes d'Israël
il n'y a presque pas de cour comme
ça
étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique]
a pris une tradition chrétienne locale Salomé
était la sage-femme qui a aidé Marie la
mère de Jésus a donné naissance à Jésus
là-bas à Bethléem, elle ne croyait pas
que Marie était restée vierge à cause de cela
sa main s'est juste gelée dans l'air à la
minute où elle a touché Jésus a attrapé sa main est
revenue à la vie,
ce qui signifie qu'elle est devenue sainte pour
Chrétiens
nous avons trouvé à l'entrée de la cour une
rangée de magasins les magasins nous avons trouvé des dizaines de
toutes les lampes à huile que nous avons trouvées au même
endroit nous pensons que les pèlerins doivent venir
louer une lampe à huile et entrer dans la
grotte funéraire que nous avions l'habitude de prier  sortez et
rendez la lampe à huile
[Musique]
étrangère